it's great to be joined today by on
kitte bhatia who's the CEO and
co-founder of Sapien which is a
customizable democratized
social news platform that rewards
content creators and curators this is
super super interesting to me so I'm
really glad to have a chance to talk to
you about it talk to me first just sort
of the genesis of this project I mean
what was sort of the problem that you
were you're hoping to solve right now
first of all thank you David for having
me
you know on your show so this sort of
idea of sapien it started some time ago
in 2015
my co-founder Robert and I we were just
sort of frustrated with the current
state of social networks we thought that
they were exploiting these our data they
weren't very democratic
you know some of these platforms had so
many users but they weren't really
taking the the users voice into account
so we decided you know at that time I
was studying computer science and Rob
had was studying mathematics and you
know we had a technical background so we
thought we would take a stab at the
social network ourselves so we started
writing some code you know it started
off as a fun sort of side project for
Sapien we were aiming to build a more
privacy focused platform that would
initially compete with Reddit and over
the years has just been sort of
expanding more and more early this year
in 2017 we began to sort of explore the
blockchain and turns out that it was
like the perfect tool for the job this
sort of new innovation will help us
create a more democratic platform and
you know we sort of inspired a lot of
people to you know follow us on this
journey yeah so talk a little bit about
like the mechanism for the
democratization right because we know
that there are some platforms where
basically you can buy your way into an
algorithm and sort of force your way
into having your content viewed there's
other platforms that work on the basis
of a reputation score but in many cases
that can sort of also be gamed there's
an early mover advantage in in many
cases how do you sort of set up the
system right so I mean the way that
we're sort of
is that we want to redefine social at
the infrastructure level so really just
from a ground up using blotching
technologies we can take a fresh take
you know at social so one of the things
you know you mentioned reputation that's
tremendously important to us that's
gonna be a sort of aspect at the level
of every user interaction on Sapien we
want to make sure that your your your
expertise is reflected in in a social
context and it's not something that you
know can just be bought right so that's
actually one of the problems that you
know one of our competitors see MIT
where you can just end up buying a lot
of the power on the platform and we
thought that that's not as Democratic as
we'd want it to be we truly feel that
your contributions should be fairly
evaluated with the consensus of the
community and you should be rewarded
based off your merits not based off you
pumping you know a lot of money into the
ecosystem how do you um how do you
establish a system for measuring that
and I'm interested in the comparison to
steam it because we publish content to
steam it it I find it to be a super
interesting platform but one of the
things I've noticed that I've talked
with people at steam it about is that
there is this sort of what I call the
whale lottery which is if you are so
lucky to be posting at a time or be
followed by a big stakeholder that
support can can represent ninety nine
ninety eight percent of the sort of
total rewards on a particular piece of
content so how can you how do you solve
that problem with Sapien right so I mean
you know off the gate we're partnering
with this company called Dow stack which
is a framework for decentralized
governance and you know when people sign
up on the site they'll all be pretty
much equal in terms of reputation and
visibility so it's just it's just a
different approach we think that is just
much better than you know the sort of
split that's happening right now between
whales and minnows people with a lot of
power and people that are just
registering on the site now we think
that you know starting off the platform
in this Democratic fashion is just it's
just it just better and along side you
know there's also some comparisons with
the
you know the actual blockchains
themselves the fact that steam is little
bit more closed versus we're really
aiming to build it on the theory on
blockchain which is you know a lot more
public and we think a more democratized
infrastructure to build also do you see
Sapien as a competitor to steam it I
think I definitely think both can
coexist we're sort of going after
different things and you know rewarding
Conti critters is big but it's definite
our holy Bali proposition we're also
very interested to see how we can create
a more fair and balanced platform that
can address the problem of fake news and
we also want to see how we can position
the platform in a way where users can
earn some of the the ad revenue they
that they generate you with the personal
data that they share so it's sort of
we're in a really unique position you
know in this time right now where we can
address a few different concerns with
current social platforms and you know
thinking is a big one and the sort of
exploit exploitation of user data that's
also something that you know we've been
passionate about since the beginning I
can talk about any of those ya know as
well yeah well I'm curious about the so
I mean right now it's very much in the
news what's been going on with data
sharing on social media by social media
networks right so can you talk a little
bit about that in terms of how I mean is
that is that the play for doing this on
the blockchain like when I talk to a lot
of AI cos they have a project project
sounds fantastic but at a certain point
we get to the question of but why do you
need the blockchain why do you need to
do this as a blockchain project why do
you need to ICO in the first place yes
is that is blockchain part of the
solution to some of these data privacy
issues exactly exactly what we're
proposing is not achievable in any other
way right like this this is the way that
we can sort of make the shift from data
slavery to data sovereignty right how we
can how we can put the data back in
control of the users so it's not just
that they have to you know sort of throw
out their data to use these services
like you know Google Facebook
YouTube all these you know there's a
there's a sort of this almost
expectation and and just this like it's
just become so normalized to share your
data to use these services I really want
to shift away from that and that's you
know one of the promises of web 3.0
we're at the end of the day the users
will be in complete control of your data
and if they choose to do so they can opt
in to see advertisements for example and
be compensated in tokens for that
alright so this is where the tokens come
into you know this whole sort of
incentive model that we can create with
tokens it just wasn't possible before
the invention of the blockchain and you
know the concept of tokens right so it's
a few different things that play how do
you anticipate dealing with issues of I
mean I hate to say issues of free speech
because it's really it's really not that
right we're really talking about sort of
censorship in some sense I mean the
great thing about decentralization and a
lot of these platforms is if it works
well good content will sort of rise to
the top and ideally as democratically
structured a system as possible but many
times for a variety of different reasons
there needs to be sort of some there
needs to be some control over possibly
illegal content content content that
incites violence or whatever the case
may be different platforms through Terms
of Service potentially can set that line
where they sort of see it best set
what's your approach to that or what
will be the Sapien policy around that
right you know that's something that you
know we've been talking about since the
beginning it's actually one of our core
values of free speech and I think you
know it's important that we do talk
about this in any emerging social
network because oftentimes you'll see
you know left-leaning platforms like
Reddit and then you'll see super
right-leaning platforms like gasps right
and you wanna you want to think about
what does the market really walk right
now right and and we sort of reach the
conclusion that we want a platform that
is fairly impartial in its approach and
doesn't sort of push an agenda in any
particular direction all right so all
everything about Sapien and this is one
of the reasons
so many people jumped on and now we have
over 20,000 people actively in our
telegram and 50,000 people all together
in different social channels but
everyone is super passionate and
understands the value that sapiens
bringing in this sort of heated time
we're looking to create a fair platform
that doesn't have its own biases and
agendas but instead our focus has always
been always been around like creating
those tools to help communities
self-regulate and you know sort of
govern themselves and that's actually
what you know one of the reasons so I
decentralized governance is going to be
really important we have to sort of
create the tools to let people decide
what's right and wrong instead of large
corporations arbitrarily deciding the
the line between free speech and
censorship so for us it's all about
giving power back to the users and you
know whether they want to set up some
sort of trials and and and call each
other out for bad behavior I think you
know we can create some interesting
incentive models with tokens to to sort
of flag illegal content for example or
you know if someone is harassing another
user you can sort of you know report
that as the community does find that as
harassment then you know maybe the user
will get banned right so this it's all
just how do you want to do it there what
types of content are sort of what you
have in mind that would be posted here I
mean you talked about fake news but how
broad would sort of the content
offerings be in your mind right it'd be
fairly broad I think you know in terms
of our like target user base we're going
after reddit first so you know reddit is
always a source of a lot of original
content and you know someone who's
subscribed to a few separate notes that
you can get a lot of information quickly
so you know initially we'll start off
with a lot of the crypto you know early
adopter base just because those are the
people that participate in our token
sale and then after that probably people
that are a little bit more tech oriented
at first just because this is going to
be a very unique platform that hasn't
been attempted
or but eventually we do want to go after
the mass market and sort of bring the
benefits of the blockchain to the masses
I think you know there's a lot been a
lot of promises in the past few months
and years about different sort of ICO
projects coming out now but I really
think now is the time that we can start
actually releasing products and you know
helping the adoption of blockchain
technologies can you talk a little bit
about how the token fits into the bigger
picture so of course the ICO has aside
from how the token will function in sort
of day-to-day operations and as its
process which Symbian is of course going
through once that's done talk a little
bit about how I mean even something as
simple as how rewards will be assigned
to content given that you will not have
this mechanism of just buying a ton of
reward power by by putting in a ton of
money mm-hmm yeah so definitely the you
know SK and utility token is deeply
integrated into the safety platform and
right off the gate it's required to
access the platform so you actually need
to hold a minimum amount of the token to
basically access the platform you know
post contribute and we call these these
versions of SP intelligence like state
SP and tokens and it's sort of you know
well described in a white paper but
essentially it sort of creates this
paradigm of something at stake so in
this case for someone who is hosting the
illegal content there's a huge
disincentive for doing so because if
they get banned they're not only gonna
leave the site but they're also going to
lose their tokens right so you'd have to
be prepared to hear some massive troll
or bought to start paying a lot of
Lawton tokens for bad behaviors there so
explain if we can't out what are the
logistics of how that works because some
people might here wait a second if I own
the tokens and it's decentralized how
could the tokens be taken away right so
I mean again like it's all about a
spectrum of decentralization so it's not
like when you say decentralization you
can't just like flip a switch and you
know go from
current centralized product to us
decentralized there is a transition
process it's not it doesn't happen
overnight but we do want to still have
control in certain areas which would
make us a sort of liability from a
business perspective right because we
slept out by by certain laws and if
something is legal it is very clearly
illegal you know at least the laws that
we're currently modeling after are the
United States laws so but you're
absolutely right I think when it comes
to specific content you know that's
something that the community will have
to decide for themselves and you know
figure out what works for them but the
token the token is you know just to
focus the conversation back on the
utility of the token we want to use it
you know in every aspect of Sapien
whether you know it's the platform for
access or you know rewards that users
can earn from posting quality content or
if they're earning a portion of the ad
revenue they'll be with Eskin tokens if
they want to buy and sell goods on the
marketplace that we want to also build
that could also be with tokens so we're
really just deeply integrating it for
all you know transactional value on this
in sapiens though can you give us the
sort of timeline overview of the
different steps and sort of when the
ideal sort of full goal live would be
right so I'd say within you know after
the token so closes we're just going to
continue developing on the on the safing
platform for a bit you know we already
have a beta that's live and you know
we're aiming for end of April of 2018 to
you know release this platform start
getting some users on and start creating
some content testing now iterating so
that all happens end of April then we're
also planning like you know within a 5
to 5 month to maybe one-year time frame
we're gonna really just focus on the
decentralized application and building
out some of these features that you know
people are very excited
to use like the advertisement platform
and rewarding contact content creators
in the decentralized way so yeah it's
basically that - scouring the community
developing out some key features and
then I think early 2019 we'll start you
know thinking about how we can scale
massively very interesting can you talk
a little bit about so the sources for
the content rewards will they be a
combination of rewards as a result of
sort of up votes or tips from users and
will there be some kind of centralized
daily reward pool or anything like that
right so definitely we actually reserved
a percentage of our tokens
I think 30% for the platform reserve and
that's going to be our sort of source of
tokens to discrete value to original
content creators and curators - so this
is I'll be that'll be what we're going
to be using for the first several months
before we implement some sort of system
to mint new tokens and this tokens will
be minted when original content is
created and potentially when new users
join the network because the value of a
network goes up as more people are in it
right like just just network effects so
our sort of goal with minting new tokens
is not to you know dilute the currency
or anything but to accurately reflect
the value that's being created in the
sabian network whether that's new users
or you know content being generated just
activity is something that you know you
can assign some token value to to that
incoming value but yeah I talked a
little bit about so this is an ER C 20
compliant and token that you're
launching talk a little bit about that
in relation to we're seeing some of the
bigger you know it's certainly been
happening with Bitcoin it's not
happening with the theory and although
there are concerns about it sort of
starting to push the limits in terms of
number of transactions and particularly
with a platform like Sapien that's meant
to be
interactive and sort of it has to
function in real-time almost in real
time you have any concerns at all about
the limits of the etherium platform hmm
oh yeah definitely as of right now we
couldn't like naively build on this
theorem blockchain right like if we
started to commit every post and
comments to the route watching that just
wouldn't scale right now and you know
we're well aware about this and we
talked about some approaches in the in
the white paper and it was plan to do a
yellow paper some some point soon now -
but in in general there's a few
strategies that have already been
working state channels is one of them
you know with this rate in network we
can create these channels that are open
and sort of do a lot of computation off
chain and then know what when we do
consolidate the information commit back
to the blocking another approach is to
do something like plasma and in that
would basically have our own plasma side
chain and then commit to the ethereum
blockchain so this would be a sort of
similar to the Lightning Network that's
in Bitcoin but applied to aetherium and
this could be a way to scale massively
and there's already been a lot of open
source developments with minimum viable
plasma UMI's ago has been working on
this you know vitalik has some you know
announced recently bell class mukesh
there's nothing like you know tons of
progress happening in this area but you
know say cannon will definitely just be
watching and you know carefully all the
different developments that are
happening and you know if if even some
other blotching comes out and cruise
itself we're not you know even
restricted to the theorem blockchain we
can just jump over to knows the liquid
it starts scaling your you know then you
know if you're really just never you
know so I mean what big picture and this
goes beyond just like your you know the
safety and ico what do you think that
this issue of transaction speed and
limitations is going to be one of the
overarching potential limiting factors
of blockchain development do you think
it'll be user adoption like the
again this goes totally beyond your ico
specifically like where do you think
blockchain could get held up right now I
think for sure it's it's the adoption
and the sort of technical complexity of
dealing with you know crypto
cryptography and public keys and private
keys I think you know even even for
Sapien one of the inspirations we get is
from coinbase right they did such a good
job on onboarding so many users and and
making sure the user experience is is is
seamless for people right so I think
until you can sort of hide the
blockchain magic in the background I
don't think you know it's gonna take off
and it honestly it's not even about the
best technology winning it's just about
who has the most number of users and and
supporters behind them so I mean people
can be you know say oh look at a like
hash map or something why isn't every
building on hash trap it's supposed to
be a superior technology but you know it
all just comes down to an adoption and
who's using what so I do think a lot of
emphasis on user experience and security
also has to be in play if you are
managing people's private keys and
making it seamless for them you got to
make sure that you know their phones are
secure and you know there's no
vulnerabilities there what are the calls
to action right now for people and if
it's different whether you're in or out
of the u.s. then definitely you know
mention that right so for Sapien you can
join our telegram community at sapien
Network s API en network that's where
we're regularly announcing new
developments and sharing our harvest
with the team and that's where the bulk
of our community lies until we migrate
through the same platform itself you can
follow us on Twitter Facebook reddit or
you know active all over social channels
just check us out on our web site
www.kpbs.org/news/evening edition
yeah thank you so much again David for
having me this was wonderful